[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants vous voyez notre
gros ours est de plus en plus élégant et
aujourd'hui il a même apporté un
parapluie montrouge pas rappelé unis
c'est un parachute ah oui oui c'est pour
descendre plus vite voir où mes deux
petits copains regardez au fait
attention attention nounours tu vas te
faire très mal
voilà le mot je veux pas me faire mal
puisque c'est un parachute
attention 1 2 3 des votes pour les
enfants une mld des mois et des mois les
offres et des moules
viens viens on va tenter d'être un lâche
en vous nommant m
j'ai voulu faire le mal
owen je me suis fait soigner gauche fait
soigner à nice étoile à la pâte ou
rousse brune à la bombe et wifi
d'affermir les médicaments ou
[Musique]
jésus est maintenant un peu de poids non
non ça va mieux
non merci je peux citer rire 1 chez les
enfants
vous m'avez bien soigné et bien marché
il ne sait plus de betty c'est promis
oui le jour procès le jury ne doute de
mettre en viennent aux mains
3 peut poindre dans cette voie du bien
même si les gens au pouvoir
[Musique]
vous voyez c'est très dangereux de jouer
au parachute avec un parapluie
il ne faut jamais faire comme gros
sources il aurait pu se faire encore
beaucoup plus mal eh bien mon pauvre
gros jours comment te sens-tu et c'est
bien fait
une autre fois tu ne t'amuses rap lui a
sauté avec un parapluie plus assez grand
pour savoir que ça ne se fait pas et
pour donner le bon exemple allons mes
petits amis au dodo en vitesse
demain rougeau sera guérie et nous
reviendrons vous voir en avant en route
gros farceur aux nuits à demain ben
[Musique]
voilà
en
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]